alors des soignants qui quittent les
hôpitaux malgré des promesses du
gouvernement est ce la cause de la
première vague qui a eu raison de leur
dévouement et ce plutôt lié à un
écoeurement face à un gouvernement qui
n'a pas tenu ses promesses
comment y remédier c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jean-paul à mon médecin généraliste
président d'honneur de la fédération des
médecins de france bonsoir à vos côtés
arnaud chiche anesthésistes fondateur du
collectif santé en danger
bonsoir nous a rejoint également alexis
poulain éditorialistes bonsoir alors
pour commencer alexis poulain votre
réaction alors il ya les soignants en
colère mais pas seulement
selon un sondage hélas paris aujourd'hui
61 % des français considèrent qu
emmanuel macron n'a pas été à la hauteur
de la situation depuis le début de la
crise du coronavirus 55% pensent qu'il
n'a pas pris les bonnes décisions sur le
plan sanitaire
c'est très sévèrement alti poulain oui
c'est sévère mais il faut voir la façon
dont cette crise a été extrêmement mal
géré on attendait en temps de crise un
état stratège on avait un état cabinet
de consulting ou finalement les
responsables dans les ministères et à
l'elysée n'ont pas su comment réagir
face à cette crise alors qu'il y ait eu
un conseil scientifique qui conseillait
mais ont manqué tous les masques qui
étaient absents les matériels de
protection des soignants qui étaient
absents les soignants qui demandait de
l'aide qui n'en recevait pas les
cliniques privées qui demandait à être
mobilisés et qui n'étaient pas
mobilisées
il n'y a eu aucune planification aucune
organisation de la réponse de l'état à
cette crise majeure
ça a été une improvisation du jour 1
jusqu'à encore maintenant aujourd'hui
malgré l'expérience de la première vague
et pourquoi bien tout simplement parce
que l'état a failli l'état n'existent
plus parce que les les énarques qui
sortent maintenant de promotion de l'ena
préfère faire carrière dans la banque
assurance dans la finance
plutôt que de venir des hommes d'état et
où des hauts fonctionnaires et et tout
ce problème là de la non planification
arrive à la fin parce que c'est une
logique celle du néo management public
qui voudrait que les services publics
n'existe plus que l'état finalement soit
uniquement un ogre régaliens justice
police et puis à peu près tout et que
l'hôpital ne soit plus un service public
loin de là mais répondre aux mêmes
logiques que le privé c'est depuis des
années les plans de santé qui se sont
accumulés et puis on a vu une stratégie
inventé par emmanuel macron pour gérer
la pénurie les masses n'étant pas là il
était inutile
or les masques il était très utile lors
du h1n1 qui était également un virus a
est reporté à l'époque il était dans le
protocole sanitaire à l'époque ils ont
été effacées du protocole sanitaire
parce qu'on n'en avait pas cette année
et tout est comme ça et on continue
aujourd'hui les ars continue de
supprimer des lits alors qu'on a besoin
de lits alors qu'on voit bien que la
santé c'est pas quelque chose qui peut
se monnayer c'est pas quelque chose qui
doit rentrer dans les cases du profit
alors en tout cas emmanuel macron était
hier à la rencontre des soignants il a
justifié
certaines de ces hausses de ses
décisions il est à l'hôpital rothschild
dans le 19e arrondissement de paris
l'occasion pour remercier les personnels
soignants on regarde et on en parle
je tiens à vous remercier tous les
soignants
pour ce qui est fait depuis des années
des cds qui est fait aussi aujourd'hui
parce que beaucoup parfois on oublie
alors au cours de ce déplacement le chef
de l'état a défendu le ségur de la santé
ce ne sont pas des promesses c'est un
accord a martelé le chef de l'état
devant des soignants sceptiques
jean paul hamon vous les comprenez ces
soignants sceptiques
écoutez je quand je comprend d'autant
mieux les soignants celtique que ça fait
un moment que le coq système par or à
dolo et puis je rappellerai quand même
au président qu un système de santé qui
marche c'est un système qui marche sur
ses deux jambes la médecine libérale la
médecine devine qui permet d'éviter les
hospitalisations inutiles qui permet
d'éviter et d'envoyer des personnes
âgées dans les ehpad le vendredi soir
parce que le vendredi soir à cause des
35 heures vous avez une infirmière
intérimaire qui peut joindre aucun
médecin et qui au grand parapluie et qui
envoie la personne âgée à l'hôpital et
qui ramène accessoirement le coc vide à
la maison et donc dans l'ehpad
donc vous avez un système qui ne marche
pas sur ses deux jambes et et c'est bien
il faut réorganiser l'hôpital mais il
faut faire une vraie communication entre
la ville et l'hôpital que la ville ait
les moyens d'éviter les hospitalisations
et de prendre en charge et
d'hospitalisation les retours rapides à
la maison voilà ce qu'il faut faire
or quand vous voulez quand vous
prétendez réformer un système de santé
et que vous vous êtes vous fait que
l'hôpital
naturellement c'est un système qui ne
sert qu'à qu'à creuser le déficit et
vous ré organisé par le système de soins
il faut éduquer les patients au bon
usage de l'hôpital vous avez 20 millions
de passages qui se font aux urgences qui
n'ont strictement rien à y faire d'après
l'igas et 20 millions de passages ça
pourrait être largement pris en charge
par la médecine de ville
on est en train d'essayer de faire
comprendre avec le service d'accès aux
soins que la régulation des débits des
personnes âgées des personnes qui
veulent soins non programmés en journée
pourrait être pris en charge par la
médecine libérale
pourvu qu'on accepte que qu'elle se
réorganise comme vous le propose et non
pas un numéro d'appel unique qui qui qui
ne va-t-il pas site strictement servir à
rien alors avant de vous donner la
parole
arnaud chiche je voudrais qu'on jette un
coup d'oeil à cet article paru ce matin
dans le canard enchaîné il est intitulé
la d
rim des primes ont regardé et vous nous
en parler
de plus en plus forte ces primes
qu'ovide non seulement des milliers de
soignants n'ayons pas eu droit
mais d'autres qui les ont touchés sont
priés de les rembourser
motif l'administration s'est trompé pour
palper les 1500 euros de bonus il
fallait avoir travaillé dans certains
services et pas dans d'autres
à certaines dates et pas à d'autres et
tant pis pour les victimes de cette
usine à gaz
or voilà une information qui interroge
arnaud chiche vous êtes citées dans cet
article est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé précisément
oui je suis cité dans cet article parce
que c'est moi qui ai donné toutes les
informations qu'elle a enchaîné
donc je remercie le canard enchaîné
d'avoir cité le collectif sont en danger
si vous voulez dans le cocktail abject
de la prise en charge des soignants en
2020 en france il ya eu aussi le
chapitre des primes
c'est à dire que effectivement les
conditions pour pouvoir toucher la prime
elle était très serré très précise et si
vous n'y étiez pas joué alors j'ai plus
les détails en tête mais il fallait être
entre certaines dates exactement ça
jouer parfois un jour près si vous
n'aviez pas là si vous manquez le jour j
la prime était reprise mais vous savez
ça en fait c'est très intéressant parce
que quand on canton de nous intéresser
au système des prix est co lead et de ce
scandale absolu
vous avez tout à fait la vision qu'a
l'état des soignants et vous avez tout à
fait les recettes de la manière dont il
traitait la santé en france
alors je vais vous dire une chose je
merci dr amont je vous ai écouté avec
attention et je pense exactement comme
vous surtout ce que vous allez d'y faire
un c ur de la santé sur l'hôpital ça ne
sert à rien il fallait faire un centre
ainsi gants sur la santé total ne les
connaître la médecine de ville
ça ne sert à rien c'est une
méconnaissance totale du système de
santé en france et vous laisser vous qui
l'avez dit monsieur vous avez parlé de
cabinet de consulting
effectivement s'il faut faire du
consulting en france pour organiser la
santé je vous conseille d'inviter le
docteur à mon jeu je me connais aussi un
petit peu et lui et moi je suis certain
qu'on fera beaucoup mieux que ce
ministère qui ne fait n'importe quoi
concernant les primes concernant le
matériel concernant les tests
qui se dit le 7 octobre comment on va
faire pour absorber cette crise je pense
que cette crise d'octobre à risque
d'être pire qu'en mars
justement rien n'a été fait justement
arnaud chiche en juillet dernier 8,1
milliards d'euros ont été débloqués pour
l'hôpital public olivier ferrand avait
promis 15 mille embauches au moment du
soccer de la santé 7500 recrutement pour
pourvoir les postes vacants 7500 postes
supplémentaires alors arnaud chiche dans
les faits on en est où aujourd'hui mais
monsieur olivier ferrand il peut
promettre tout ce qu'il veut il peut
promettre 50 il passe t'il si il ne
touche pas aux salaires des soignants
haut niveau qui est nécessaire c'est à
dire 300 euros et 2 passes en 81 s'il ne
s'intéresse pas aux effectifs dans les
établissements de santé
si le s'intéresse pas aux ratios une
infirmière pour combien de patients
s'ils ne s'intéressent pas de près mais
moi si ma gamine elle me dit un jour
qu'elle est infirmière je lui dis mais
ne fais jamais ça
allez voir dans les ehpad qui se passe
le cieux les ehpad
c'est un scandale d'état comme il ya pas
assez de personnel on diminue le
personnel le week-end comprenez donc en
fait la toilette et les l'intimité des
personnes âgées alitées le week-end
c'est moi c'est moi important donc on
peut créer cinquante mille postes
il faut donner envie aux gens de faire
ce métier là qui est un métier
formidable formidable mais aujourd'hui
les jeunes
est ce que vous croyez qu'ils ont envie
d'aller prendre un job où ils vont
risquer leur vie parce qu'on n'en parle
pas assez de saint jo rappelle qu'en
mars et 70 morts enfin parmi les
soignants et pas des gens très âgés un
des mères de famille déjà de médecins
retraités qui étaient venus aider on
n'en parle pas c'est moi j'ai envie d'en
entendre parler tous les jours
donc en fait aujourd'hui avec des
conditions très mauvaises
on voudrait que les gens viennent ces
gens là ils croient au père noël
c'est vrai comme ça que ça se passe
jean-paul avons justement pour reprendre
ce métier de soignant à attractif pour
le rendre attractif comme on fait
aujourd'hui selon vous on évite de
prendre des arrêtés comme celui qui a
été pris le 6 mars en pleine pandémie
par je ne sais qui au ministère
permettant aux infirmières
et aux pharmaciens d'apprendre à palper
les lombaires dans le cadre des
infections urinaires avec une formation
de quatre heures alors si vous voulez
quand vous voyez ça que vous découperez
ça après la pandémie parce que vraiment
au mois de mars on avait autre chose à
que de regarder les arrêtés du
ministère cc la médecine c'est la
médecine en dix jours vous apprenez à
regarder une gorge en trois heures à
écouter un coeur en trois heures à
palper les lombaires en quatre heures
ces gens là sont complètement paniqué
parce que la france est en train de se
désertifier de sa médecine libérale et
sa médecine de proximité tous les
français savent quelles difficultés ils
ont à trouver un médecin traitant moi je
suis dans une commune on a perdu on a
perdu six médecins généralistes et y en
a quatre qui exercent qui ont plus de 70
ans dont moi dont je peux vous dire que
là la france est en train de se
désertifier et et on a une
administration qui pensent que en
déléguant toutes les tâches tous les
actes qu'ils pensent simples qui sont en
train de dégrader la qualité prise en
charge des patients je peux vous dire
que les internes qui viennent chez moi
dans mon cabinet se demande quels
métiers vont exercer qui vont exercer
quand on sait que les pharmaciens vont
traiter entre guillemets les angines qui
vont traiter les infections urinaires
après avoir palpé les lombaires ou après
a pas appris à palper les lombaires
pendant quatre heures que la
téléconsultation on va se déployer avec
des plateformes de téléconsultation kivu
siphonne vos données médicales et vos
données tout court dr sy qui se mêlent
de ferrer delà de la téléconsultation
avec une dégradation de la qualité de
prise en charge du patient parce que
vous êtes pris en charge en télé
consultation par un médecin qui ne vous
connaît pas donc
et là on voit que entre la
téléconsultation les transferts de
tâches etc
on voit que lala lala une dégradation
constante de la qualité prise en charge
des patients une france qui se
désertifient et des jeunes médecins qui
se disent mais quel médecin quel métier
on va exercer
quand en plus après une crise majeure
comme celle là qu'on avait une occasion
unique de réformer le système de santé
on se contente de bricoler une
une mesure hâtives sur l'hôpital même
s'il ya de l'argent effectivement qui
est mis mais effectivement je comprends
les soignants parce que est facile
adepte de l'hôpital de 10 milliards
c'est bien ça peut-être père m'aide à
peut-être d'investir mais mais en tous
les cas le il voit pas l'argent arrivé
sur leur compte alors alexis poulain
justement à propos d'argent emmanuel
macron ir l'a dit ce n'est pas une
question de moyens mais une question
d'organisation est ce que vous partagez
ce constat du président pour l'hôpital
pas du tout d'ailleurs c'est un problème
l'organisation ce sont les cabinets de
conseil en organisation que ce soit les
mac kinsey les bayne les parts et on y
voyait et autres qui sont à l'origine du
manque d'argent de l'hôpital parce
qu'ils ont fait de l'hôpital public de
la santé un centre de profit et ces gens
là sont à la manoeuvre depuis des années
derrière les plans déficiences des
hôpitaux
c'est eux qui ne connaissent pas le
métier il est temps que les médecins
reprennent le pouvoir et vire les
comptes de tous les cabinets de
consulting
ça suffit c'est les médecins qui doivent
faire la santé c'est pas des gens qui
parce que c'est un marché important vont
expliquer aux politiques qui sont là
parce que voilà on les a élus mais
parfois on se demande pourquoi comment
faire pour faire de l'argent économisé
de l'argent on se rend bien compte que
la santé publique
elle coûte de l'argent mais qu'elle ne
peut fonctionner qu'effectivement la
médecine libérale est en bonne forme il
ya vous avez au sein des chantres de la
start up nation des gens qui pensent
qu'on peut faire sans argent avec de
l'innovation
je suis désolé en réanimation il ya eu
très peu d'innovation ces vingt
dernières années
les médicaments sont les mêmes on a
besoin de bras de lits et de médecins
qui font des diagnostics en amont pour
que justement arrive en réanimation le
moins de gens possible qu'ils soient
traités en avant par des médecins
libéraux par exemple et qu'il ne soit
pas ni aux urgences ni dans des lits de
réanimation et ça c'est pas l'innovation
technique c'est pas effectivement la
lette le télé consulting de d'octo livre
où ce genre de truc qui va faire qu'on
va faire des bons diagnostics c'est des
médecins c'est à dire arrêtez avec le
numéro solo duos formés correctement les
gens paient correctement les soignants
dans l'hôpital public
donc oui si on met des milliards sur la
table c'est pour recruter des gens c'est
pas pour inventer encore un
un truc comme stop go vide ou des
applications miracle qui vont servir à
rien à part rationaliser les
responsables du désastre actuel sont
ceux qui font du conseil
et ils sont encore à la manoeuvre c'est
eux qui font de ségur de la santé c'est
le cabinet de ben & consulting qui fait
le déconfinement au nom de jean castex
voilà donc les tableaux excel ça suffit
maintenant faisons confiance aux
médecins ils savent ce qu'il faut pour
que la santé fonctionne en france alors
justement on a deux médecins on va
pouvoir s'intéresser à la stratégie
sanitaire du gouvernement avec toujours
cette question des tests elle a été mise
en avant par le gouvernement avec le
nombre très nombreux tests effectués
chaque semaine
alors on ne sait pas s'ils sont positifs
mais contagieux ou pas ça on sais pas
encore je vous propose d'écouter
alexandra aurions caudal et généticienne
ancienne directrice directrice de
l'inserm elle était sur ce plateau lundi
soir au lait coûte lorsqu'on est positif
on va avoir entre voilà cinquante pour
60% certains disent 90% de chances de ne
pas être porteur de moindre symptôme
donc on est en train de parler de cas
quand finalement la majorité façon vous
avez dix 62% sainfoin 10,90 qu'importe
n'allons pas dans les chiffres la
majorité est véritablement 105 900
coville il ya plusieurs raisons à cela
c'est qu'en fait on demande à ce test de
nous renseigner sur ce qui ne peut pas
faire c'est à dire la contagiosité ordon
chiche sur cette question des tests de
la contagiosité qu'on ne sait pas encore
mesurer
on en est où aujourd'hui effectivement
haskell c'est une piste qu'on doit
creuser selon vous écoutez je je je
pense sincèrement que la stratégie du
dépistage d'isoler de 2,2 d'identifier
les cas contacts et sur le papier une
bonne stratégie
je trouve que effectivement ça peut
avoir du sens mais mais il faut que les
moyens soient mis en regard et soignants
en soit à la hauteur de cette
organisation
or qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
on s'est lancés en dépistage massif
médiatique de tel ou tel quartier ça
n'avait aucun sens on a gâché des
réactifs ce qui fait que la situation
mi-septembre 5 septembre alors là je
sais pas il paraît que ça va un peu
mieux mais il faut que je vérifie
qu'est ce qui s'est passé la main moi
dans mon entourage dans l'eau de france
lille 1 quand même hein qu'est la
troisième ou la quatrième ville de
france pour prendre un rendez-vous
c'était une semaine de délai parfois et
le résultat c'était une semaine à dix
jours
avec une stratégie comme ça vous fait
rien et alors là c'est pareil c'est
pareil je ne sais pas d'où ça vient mais
celui qu'a imaginé faire des tests
massif alors qu'on n'a pas assez
réactifs cas pressurisée les
laboratoires il faut voir le mal être du
personnel des labos les files d'attentes
l'angoissent le côté anxiogène que ça
crée dans les familles de pas par moi et
moi dans ma famille il m'appelait arnaud
n'a besoin de se faire tester
alors moi je vais aller faire tester
parce qu'on passait par par des chemins
détournés
j'ai triché un peu mais cissé s'est
complètement ça n'a pas été décidée par
des médecins c'est pas possible
donc en fait mille fois d'accord avec
vous monsieur l'éditorialiste ce poulain
oui bien évidemment oui
les médecins doivent être à la
gouvernance du système de soins français
en collaboration avec des administratifs
moi je suis pas un administratif il ya
probablement des choses que je ne sais
pas mais ce que je sais que certitude
c'est quand il a fallu sauver les
français en mars en france ça s'est bien
passé parce que les médecins s'en sont
occupés et personne d'autre et quand moi
j'interrogeais mon ars elle était
mutique
alors je répète quand j'interroge aimons
ars
elles étaient multiples et c'est parce
que le bon sens des médecins le bon sens
des soignants s'est mis en branle qu'on
a organisé les choses en mars mais la
moindre des choses ça aurait été en
tirer des conclusions
même des bonnes choses et de toutes les
mauvaises choses aussi et même les
bonnes choses il aurait fallu les
organiser pour qu'elle soit appliquée
dès septembre
il manque à cette santé en français ce
gouvernement un choc de bon sens c'est
tout ce choc de bon sens sept mille
médecins à travers le monde ont signé
une tribune
il préconise la protection des plus
faibles et laisser les autres finalement
atteindre l'immunité
collective regardez et vous réagissez
jean paul hamon les politiques actuelles
de confinement produisent des effets
désastreux sur la santé publique
à court moyen et long terme parmi les
conséquences
on peut citer entre autres une baisse
des taux de vaccination chez les enfants
une aggravation des cas de maladies
cardiovasculaires une baisse des examens
pour de possibles cancer ou encore une
détérioration de la santé mentale en
général cela va engendrer de grands
excès de mortalité dans les années à
venir notamment dans la classe ouvrière
est parmi les plus jeunes
alors jean paul avant si l'hôpital n'est
plus en mesure d'assurer sa mission
faute d'effectifs et de moyens
est ce que c'est une stratégie qui
devrait être mis sur la table selon vous
a écouté je peux en parler puisque j'ai
j'avais même proposé ça en mars de
mettre les personnes fragiles à l'abri
de les mettre vraiment à l'abri et de
laisser courir le virus heureusement
qu'on l'a pas fait parce que c'est ce
qui a été fait en suède et en suède
malgré une population particulièrement
disciplinés et qui respectent les
mesures barrières
c'est eux qui ont eu le taux de mort le
plus important parmi les pays nordiques
et clairement si on avait fait ça
l'hôpital qui a été au bord de la
rupture complète au board de choisir les
patients qu'ils allaient soigner parce
qu'il y avait plus de places en
réanimation au moment du confinement la
l'hôpital aurait été absolument
dé-bor-dée donc effectivement c'est
tentant de laisser courir
l'épidémie est de protéger les personnes
fragiles mais je peux vous dire que pour
ça il faudrait avoir un système
hospitalier avec avec des réalisations
et on prend un grand risque sur le plan
sur le plan des morts non ce qu'il faut
c'est c'était su ce qui a été fait c'est
à dire que tester tester isolé mais mais
seulement pour tester effectivement
depuis le mois de septembre ça commence
seulement à s'arranger
ces derniers jours mais il a fallu
attendre des fois dix jours pour avoir
un test avec des gens qui se détester
trois fois la semaine sans problème
parce que bon il y avait décidé de le
faire et puis que c'était open bars dans
les bars dans les dents est dans les
open bird aller dans les laboratoires
donc si vous voulez là il ya eu un
système qui était complètement déconnant
qu'il faut c'est avoir les tests
rapidement de façon à voir les résultats
des tests rapidement y compris à voir
les tests antigénique rapide qu'on peut
avoir 15 20 minutes lasser c'est dans
nos cabinets et qu'il est faux de façon
à ce qu'on puisse isolé gens qu'on
puisse distinguer la co vite de la
grille peut éventuellement du vrs pour
décider d'une stratégie met rapidement
en isolant les personnes en identifiant
les corons tac et en confinant les gens
voilà ce qu'il faudrait faire
seulement pour ça il faudrait qu'on
dispose de test dans nos cabinets que
les laboratoires qui commence à rendre
les résultats en 24-48 heures rendre
vraiment les résultats dans les 12 24
heures pour qu'on puisse agir rapidement
c'est ça qu'il faudrait seulement on
savait que c'est ce virus continue de
circuler cet été on voyait bien que dès
qu'il y avait un écart je pense aux
clusters qui a eu dans le bar de
quiberon ou le type avait transformé son
bar en boîte de nuit il y avait trois
positifs pour se retrouver avec 54
positif en une nuit
donc on savait que ce virus allait
recommencer à circuler à partir du
moment où l'école allait reprendre le
travail allait reprendre et des
transports allait reprendre
donc tout ça on le savait donc on
pouvait anticiper et permettre aux
laboratoires d'analysés d'acheter
suffisamment machine pour que l'on
puisse produire les tests rapidement et
ne pas se retrouver quand même on est
quand même quasiment à la mi octobre
ça redémarre et depuis le mois de
septembre ça continue d'augmenter
doucement on sait mieux traiter les gens
en réanimation
peut-être qu'ils vont rester moins
longtemps en réanimation et que le
système pourra tenir mais on en n'est
absolument pas sûr puisque la
actuellement on est en train on commence
déjà reporté d'eads et des opérations
qui étaient prévus pour libérer des lits
en réanimation
donc si vous voulez tout ça un peu
d'anticipation denrées produits et puis
un peu de compétences aussi merci à tous
les trois pour votre décryptage merci à
vous alexis poulain rappelle que vous
êtes éditorialistes merci à vous jean
paul hamon un médecin généraliste
président d'honneur fédération des
médecins de france
merci également à voir nos chiche
anesthésiste